coming up on Star Talk special edition
will AI be the end of civilization
well but before that happens will it
help us coach Sports better
will it make deep fakes that will
destabilize
all that we know and trust
or can believe in in this world also
will it help us explore space all that
and more coming up
[Music]
this is startalk's Special Edition
an entire show right now devoted to AI
we we don't know is AI good or bad it's
bad you heard all about it everybody's
opining on it uh do is it a problem
solver it's a problem or does it create
problems uh how do we use it in space
and media in in all kinds of places
here we are back with Chuck knife Chuck
how you doing man my co-host sorry to
tell you but this is not me I'm not here
you see
this is this is uh my uh AI doppelganger
that's that's your doppelganger all
right now I have ways to test for that
we'll find out in a minute here's the
problem the the AI has me tied up in the
closet help me please someone help me
uh Gary yes how you doing man I'm good
I'm interested in this because it's not
a subject I have any real depth of
knowledge about which is most subjects I
agree but um
he's a lion Gary's also tied up in the
closet is right next to me in the closet
man
all right
um all right so I'll do my best with
your two doppelgangers so here we go
Gary set the scene what do we have here
all right today's guest has a doctorate
in mathematics from Oxford that studies
Oxford uh was researching astrophysics
and then decided to switch to AI author
yes published author of a book in 2018
called Factor man developed and I love
this thing developed a computer program
called Dr Phil that's f-i-l that solves
crossword puzzles and Dr Phil has
competed in professional crossword
puzzle tournament successfully and now
this gentleman works for the delightful
people at Google so today's guest none
other than a dear friend Matt Ginsburg
who's returning to StarTalk Matt
Ginsburg welcome back Matt Ginsburg hey
it's great uh it's great to be talking
to you all again
um I think at the end we probably should
have a vote on whether we want to let
Chuck and Gary out of the closet or
whether we prefer the doppelganger yeah
whether these are better versions right
so Matt you what did what are you doing
with Google right now or are you on some
kind of NDA non-disclosure agreement so
I work for an organization called X it
is part of alphabet we are alphabet's
moonshot Factory which is just to be
clear alphabet is the holding company of
Google
alphabet it's a holding company of
Google and other organizations
part of Google or X in alphabet it
sounds like it belongs in alphabet X is
an alphabet okay we're not part of
Google we're in alphabet I I gotta tell
you something for a guy who went to
Oxford I ain't so impressed that you
know that X is in the alphabet okay
that's actually Fair
um we do the hardest stuff we can think
of right it's an unbelievably fun place
to work the people are incredibly smart
we have a project this is like the Xbox
in that Spirit it is next prize was
money for just some as we say moonshot
something that right who thought you
could make this happen and you do if you
put enough smart people uh funded by
enough money and then there it is is it
true that they call it the failure
division of of Google because they don't
care if you fail it's all about you know
the discovery of information and and
advancement through doing stuff that you
would never otherwise attempt so we have
this project
called tapestry the goal is to
decarbonize the electric grid so
everybody uses Renewables and huge
climate impact cool that is so hard it
is that if we can't do it nobody's going
to be stunned right any specific project
that X is probably more likely to fail
and succeed right but there are some
amazing successes so waymo
which is alphabet self-driving car
division came out of x
we have another project called mineral
that just graduated that has these weird
vehicles that drive around
the tracks between crops on a farm on a
farm and they use cameras and Machine
Vision to figure out how the plants are
doing and just generally to make farming
more efficient wow all of these things
are things that that were just as hard
as tapestry when they started
but they've actually succeeded and now
they're out as I mean we their bets
they're part of alphabet so we call them
bets and these are other decisions I
like that
cool um but not and it's I have to tell
you it's great working for a company
that expects you to do unbelievably hard
things and realizes that when you try
and do things that hard
you're not always going to pull it off
right right well of course science in
general has many many failures the Press
only talks about the successes so uh you
starting out in science this would not
have been a foreign concept to you other
than that there's a whole company that's
cool with it normally it'll make the
bottom line you're on the street you
know the next the next quarter
exactly and you know I tell my friends
who are in projects that eventually get
shut down because they didn't work I say
you know you always learn more from a
success from a failure than from a
success
so we should celebrate the failures and
we do we actually when it should come
when an effort gets shut down there's a
big meeting everybody applauds it's like
a party because we know that we've
learned stuff we know that we've tried
stuff
and we know that now we're going to try
something new and enough of it works
that the whole Enterprise
you know is something that
you can justify that to uh you know the
short-sighted
um desires of shareholders because
no no here's what you do it you act we
ask a different question so Matt what
percent of Google's
annual revenue gets directed towards X
that is covered by an NDA that that is
covered by an NDA it is in our it is an
r d effort that tries to do the crazy
things
um all the stuff that we're going to
talk about about generative AI is based
on a technology called Transformers that
came out of a part of Google called
brain brain came out of x
so waymo came out of X we've we've done
amazingly impactful things we have a
long time frame so we start a project
it's not you know it's common for us to
say this is going to take 10 years we
might kill it in two because we can tell
that it's not working but if it succeeds
it's going to take 10 years we're okay
with that
so the hard part from from the
shareholders is not arguing that we're
adding value I think I think we're
clearly adding value we have to get them
to be patient enough to see that value
materialize right okay and you're lucky
man because there's a cult there's a
culture there I saw it once or twice
when I was playing where if you did lose
defeated beaten heavily people went away
licked their wounds but considered where
the things went wrong came back with
Solutions if you build that culture
you can achieve things by using that way
but the pressure to get results and as
Chuck was so rightly pointing out it's
dollars I don't have time because I'm
committing such a phenomenal amount of
money to this and if we lose too many
games my coach gets fired all sorts of
things so it's it's a really really
fascinating place if you can develop a
sustained culture like that we do have
the culture and alphabet has been
fantastic about recognizing that there
is room in a in an entity as successful
as alphabet
to have a bunch of people to let them
take the Long View to let them try and
do incredibly hard things and see what
happens and obviously we can't just keep
failing some stuff eventually has to
work but some stuff does work and the
the people at X who decide what are we
going to work on when are we going to
kill it when are we going to keep
pushing it they seem to be very good
about
ensuring that
net net were a positive
can you comment just reflect on a recent
AI news story about a John Lennon song
where they sample John Lennon's voice
and then had him finish the song because
he died before it was recorded yeah can
you just reflect on is that a good thing
or a bad thing or
that's a complicated thing
I think that
um
what would Jesus do he said what would
John Lennon do
if he were here would he punch you in
the nose like what would he do
more Beatles songs I think are an
undeniably good thing
I think
there are two things I think you want to
take away from this look at what they
chose to synthesize they synthesized
Lenin's voice yep what made the Beatles
so magical
is I think the words what they chose to
say that's much harder synthesizing a
person's voice is relatively speaking
easy so the first thing I think we need
to think about is
synthesizing a voice and synthesizing
the idea the essence different things
and the second thing is the fact that
you can synthesize someone's voice is
scary because it's going to make deep
fakes so much more of a problem than
they currently are because now
we can make a picture of whoever doing
whatever
and we can even attach some voice to it
to convince you that it really happened
when in fact it didn't really happen so
I think that's a big issue that huge
that will need to be addressed
if we're going to keep
all of society sort of continue to be
grounded in reality as opposed to these
Fabrications but so we need to think
about that now because if we don't come
up with some way to Watermark this
technology on a digital level
I mean what is going to what is going to
stop people from utilizing it in the
most heinous ways possible nothing
nothing
so that's you're absolutely right
um watermarking is tricky because you
can I mean you can pass a law saying all
digitally created images must be
watermarked okay and then somebody
creates an image in a country that
doesn't have the law
and it's on the internet and now what do
you do I think the the way we have to
deal with this
um I think there are a couple of things
one is
we need to develop the technology
so right now there are programs that can
recognize Bard which is Google's
generative AI that you can talk to and
if you give it a text it was written by
Bart they can say yeah 95 that was
written by Bard not by a human we need
to use those to understand what was
created and what was not and the same
thing can be said of images there are
there are non-watermark traces that we
need to better understand and better
make take advantage of and the second
thing is
we need to recognize that there are
trusted sources
and we need to pay attention to
this came from somewhere that
I actually am willing to believe
if they say they took the picture they
took the picture it actually happened so
a news agency potentially can serve this
role in the way that some guy
somewhere far away who just creates a
picture might not be a trusted source
and we as a society have to be more
suspicious sadly than we have been that
just because somebody shows me a picture
it doesn't mean it's true we've
discussed some of the positivity and
some of the negativity but if we take
the intelligence part of AI have we
actually since we've been started to
play with the developer kind of pointed
it in the right direction to do the
right things or if we kind of just
wasted our time with it so far
I don't think we've wasted our time okay
okay first of all so I think there are
um
there are lots of applications of AI
that have been phenomenally successful
incredibly important
the car that you just bought was
probably manufactured mostly by robots
the cars have fewer defects coming off
the line absolutely they're cheaper
it's a good are they
well there's inflation but I think
um Pathfinder right we want to send a
robot to Mars because we can
we don't have the technology to send
people to Mars yet but we can send our
agents there in the form of these
automated devices they have to be pretty
independent because round trip message
time to Mars is long you know the robot
has to avoid Iraq all by itself because
you don't talk to it you can't talk
Cliff so quick watch out for the cliff
20 minutes later it's too late or the
Martians
so I think we've done good things I
think that AI is moving very fast at the
moment and when technology moves quickly
it's challenging it's always been
challenging for society to keep up and
for society to say okay here's what I
have to think about here's how the world
has actually changed it's important that
Society distinguished from the apparent
changes which aren't actually grounded
in in reality
from when actually has happened that
matters so for example all these
generative programs barred and others
they're not actually smart they don't
actually know what's going on but it's
very easy for people to think they're
smart and to ask them for explanations
about which they're completely poorly
equipped to respond
as opposed to asking them things that
they can respond to so for example
somebody asked me recently if Bard
understood causality they wanted to
understand some colorful thing or lack
of a causal thing so he said Can Bart
understand causality and I said okay and
I went to Bard and I said is there a
correlation between the phase of the
moon and the amount of chicken eaten in
Denmark
and it said absolutely
and it it quoted a paper that had never
actually been written in a survey that
had never actually even done it just
made all this stuff up that was and I
told my son about this and he said dad
why are you asking Bard questions like
this it's not going to answer them
but if I want I'm a new business and I
want to have a website and I can't
afford a developer I can go to Bard and
say make me a website
that does this and Bartle do great
so
we all of us need to understand what
these entities can do what they can't do
what they're going to be effective at
what they're going to be ineffective at
and we need to ask them to do what they
are good at which is a lot it's just not
everything they're not going to you know
replace all of us
all good news
for you apparently fine because you're
in the Closet near this is just the
chocolate
well well played Matt yes
Matt if as soon as I've been talking
about robots in Mars what would you have
to build into a program for it to
look into deep space
and find things that we don't look don't
know to look for just yet
how how do you go about tweaking AI to
be able to achieve that or is it not
quite there yet
I think it's mostly not quite there yet
so the way these things work
is so here's here's here's how I often
think of it the world breaks down into
what I call 5149 problems where
you want to be 50 51 right is good so if
you're playing the stock market
and you can accurately pick stocks that
are going up 51 of the time you're about
to be really rich
and then you have hundred zero problems
where 51 is not good enough 99 is not
good enough if you're trying to shut
down a nuclear reactor in an emergency
you really need the 100 answer yep all
of these machine learning systems are
incredibly good at the 5149 stuff and
they're not so good at the hundred zero
stuff
so if you want to look in deep into deep
space and you're really interested in
something that you thought was
probability zero
an alien talking to us or a new kind of
supernova or something that we have
never seen before
that's sort of a hundred zero problem
recognizing things whose probability is
actually zero and it's a huge surprise
machine learning systems are not great
at that but no I I don't agree wait wait
nerdfight in the progress here okay
uh so Matt I agree with I in principle
agree with you but there's an important
Nuance here because I can program the
computer
to show me something right that I don't
recognize because I have a huge catalog
of things I do recognize no matter what
it is
finally broad but it's something that we
haven't we know we haven't seen it
because the computer knows our entire
catalog correct the Kuda has everything
that we know and something shows up that
we don't know and I say
storming everything we don't know
because that's that's going to be
anonymous because it's going to be an
anomalous one of the gazillion thing yes
or it could just be a glitch in The
Matrix but it'll find it though and so
that's why I I don't entirely agree it's
not good it at least astrophysically in
finding the the the Lone Wolf out there
so the trick is what you're asking is
find the one that doesn't belong correct
and these programs will classify
everything you give them eight things
and they'll say oh my God this belongs
in pot seven oh my God so whether you
want it to or not is what you're saying
no it's the decision to do so on its own
even if it creates a category that
didn't exist and says well now it's in
this category well it'll probably put it
in an existing category okay
wait wait wait hang on hang on hang on
what you can do don't make me come out
there somebody
get me some popcorn this nerdfight's
getting good
what you can do is you can say if the
frequency is outside of a frequency I've
ever seen flagging if the periodicity is
shorter than anything I've ever seen
flag it but what you're doing now is you
are actually creating sort of a new
category of
surprising things that you are defining
for the system
and then saying what belongs in that
category absolutely you can do that but
if you see a true surprise something
that you actually had no idea was going
to exist so for example imagine that
you find a pulsar
and miraculously
the phase of the Pulsar is one hundred
percent correlated with the phase of
another Pulsar two light years away
that's amazing
something totally bizarre is going on
but the machine won't know because it
has no idea to look because it doesn't
have it doesn't happen it's not a new
object it's a it's a new phenomenon
right
right so right these things that are
that are brand new things it'll just
look at that it'll say Pulsar next right
yeah exactly so okay all right I'll give
you that yeah so what you're saying is
it doesn't know to look for it because
we don't know the looks for it
correct but yeah I was I was being blunt
about it and saying objects and
phenomena that are sort of singular that
you would just put in a catalog with
properties we use yes
searching throughout data to find weird
stuff all the time but you are right if
there are two pulsars that are
synchronized we know what pulsars are we
know what they're what their pulses look
like and they're synchronized because
aliens are getting ready for the
invasion we would have no idea nobody
would find that that's correct exactly
but but what would happen if this
happened people would say holy cow these
pulsars are synchronized and then they
would Define a new thing which is a
synchronized Pulsar pair
and then all of a sudden that would go
into our category and now we would talk
about that Pulsar pair as an object and
all of a sudden the neural net would say
oh Pulsar pair I've seen that before
this is a pulsar pair but the first time
you see one of these fundamentally new
phenomena
which is what makes science fun in all
honesty
machines don't know
it's too far outside you know what
they've been trained to do so we go to
retrain them
ourselves
I think but tonight puts a limit on ai's
ability to explore for us so it does so
right now and I've I've said this before
on the show
what we're good at and what machines are
good at are different yeah we are
incredibly good at Holy Cow two
synchronized pulsars who'd have thought
it
I gotta pay attention to that
we're amazing at that
machines are they're amazing at
this thing that you can barely see over
here I looked at it 18 different ways
it's probably a pulsar they're better
than we are but right now we can do more
with machines at our side than either of
us could do in isolation and I think
that's great I'm incredibly optimistic
because of that I I don't see and the
day is coming somewhere
way far away
but right now I don't see that
they can get by without us any better
than we can get by without that we're
using the Better Together scenario let's
flip it into my Backyard Sports
could AI become a live in-game play
coach a head coach
in real time the answer that is yes and
I and I have I have built an NFA play
NFL play caller I have run it in
simulation against the choices made by
actual play callers and it crushes them
it just annihilates them and it's easily
fast enough I actually I I played with
it before joining X I played with it and
I had it and I actually was watching
football games with this and it would
put in real time this is what you should
do and I would watch the coach do what
he did and and then I ran all these
simulations people are
unfortunately I guess not terribly good
play callers play calling is this giant
statistics problems machines are going
to be great at that right and they're
great at it fast however having this
does does your program take into account
the adjustments that are made by
quarterbacks who recognize coverage
in real time so the defense plays a call
and the officer the answer is yes it
does yeah
that's the wrong question does your
program deflate the ball
[Laughter]
no that's the right question so the
answer to the answer to Chuck's question
is that part of my software was who's
the quarterback okay that's enough
because the quarterbacks that are
effective at adapting to what they see
when they come to the line exactly are
going to have slightly different
statistics than the quarterbacks who are
not effective amazing so when the
program decides do I want to call Iran
do I want to call a pass where do I want
to call past two
it does know
but how I I lost I missed something here
since you
how do you what do you mean you do
better than the actual
call players because you don't have an
outcome that you can look at you just
shouldn't have done that should have
done what I said so I had he done what
you said how do you know what the
outcome would have been so there don't
so there are two ways first I as any uh
any coaches based on a simulation engine
so I could I can run that simulation now
it's sort of a self-licking ice cream
cone because yes it is okay so that's
way one and I think there's still merit
there because you can test the actors of
the simulation the second thing I can do
is I can just go back and look at the
game and say okay
the plays where the actual human coach
made my Play A B C D E the place where
he made a different play f g h i j and
then I can look at him and say oh ABC
worked out pretty well fghj they were
duds and it's easy to look after the
fact and see whether a play was a
success or a failure but aren't you
still just invoking the statistics of
past events
but that's reasonable right so there's
no reason yes isn't that what they're
doing every single pitch in baseball
today everything is they're over
analyzing it right in baseball why are
they not doing that in football
so maybe they are
I so that I don't know I do think that
baseball is a little more committed to
the statistics of the sport
between yeah I also think that
um
the extent to which
so so what you're asked at some level
what you're asking is how hard is it to
build a machine learning or other model
that tells you how effective a pitch
will be how effective uh football play
will be that is able to predict with
reasonable accuracy whatever whatever
that is is able to predict the outcome
of a particular sporting choice
the answer is
it's
it's not it's not super hard and it's
not super easy right you have to get the
data there's a lot of curation involved
you have to use reasonably modern
techniques that's what I did with the
NFL thing and it worked pretty well
I was able to tell what was the actual
answer it was a while ago I think I was
I was able to predict run versus pass
with very high accuracy and I was able
to predict exactly what play would be
called something like 20 of the time
damn so I very very high for football 20
that's insane could you imagine a
football team on this being on the
sidelines aside from a Belichick team
that's stealing the signals if you could
imagine being on the sideline and with
high accuracy knowing
at 20 one out of every five plays you
would know that what they're going to do
you would
yeah this is part of
why the software why the simulations
indicated that a machine coach
is is really going to do very well
against a human cook that's amazing I
know but what if you put what if you put
one against another you know my AI is
better than your race
again coach oh it's the Decepticons
versus the Autobots do they cancel each
other out they they sort of cancel each
other out so you know if you let's go to
chats which is sort of less
controversial
so you can have even a relatively poor
chess program now is way better than the
best human right but there are still
better programs and worse programs right
so the same thing can happen here now
you have additional facet factors in
sports because one of the teams May well
be simply more physically talented than
another team true and then the question
becomes can a difference in the quality
of the coaches whether they're ARS or
not overcome the difference in the
physical qualities of the team and do
you want to allow that I don't know but
there will be better AIS and worse AIS
yeah how big those differences are I
don't know because right now there are
no AIS but
that's going to be another facet of what
makes a team good
Matt is the the sports organizations be
whichever sport are already using AI
technology for in-game situations I
think it's pretty small yeah it's when I
joined X I was I was trying to talk to
the NFL about using the software develop
for play calling and it was it seemed
pretty clear to me that they weren't
doing anything like that yeah yeah now
I've been an extra couple of years so
we're looking back two years yeah I
think that eventually
this is going to happen but of course
not yet but it's moving towards that
because right now you're using next-gen
and next-gen stats and what they're used
what they're looking at is a percentage
uh like likelihood
um and probabilities for certain plays
at certain times you've never seen more
two-point conversions in the NFL than
you have right now that is a direct
result of uh statistically you should do
it you've never seen more teams going
for fourth and whatever uh because
statistically you should do it so we're
moving towards that direction so about
that specifically
about I was probably eight years ago now
I did some statistical work for the
Oregon Ducks
and I told the coach at the time I gave
him these huge printouts with what you
should do in every situation on fourth
down and I said just stop hunting
between the 35 yard lines that's really
what it all says and he stopped and that
was the year of it the Oregon Ducks were
the best they were
and the other college teams noticed and
they stopped punting between the 35-yard
lines and you're absolutely right what
has happened at the NFL level is people
have noticed so when I see someone not
punting between the 30 not going forward
on fourth down I smile because it's
basically my work that the statistical
work I did a while ago to
get the Oregon Ducks to stop doing it
and then it propagate it out so well
just to understand on fourth down rather
than punt to release the to to
um return the ball to the opposing team
you they would go for first down and at
some percent of the cases they don't but
if I'm on my own 35-yard line I'm
handing you the ball at the 35-yard line
right and you're saying that risk is not
as great as just handing over the ball
because they might have gotten a first
down and kept no you're only starting 10
10 yards further than uh than you would
if I had if you had made a fair Catch
yeah so if you're only conceding 10
yards you're conceding 10 yards by going
for it I mean by not going for it that's
all you're really giving up you know
unless there's a really good return now
does it take that into account because
that's fast it took everything into
account okay so yeah if you've got a
great return guy you know that's that's
also it's also a function of how late in
the game is it and how much are you
ahead or behind by the actual rules it
turns out if we're doing sports is don't
punt between the 35 yard lines and
always go for it on fourth and one even
from your own 10. whoa
and I told that to the Oregon Ducks
coach and he said I can't do that I'll
lose my I'll lose my job yeah bye get
replaced from a straight yes from a
straight statistical perspective
the and the bottom line is if you punt
from your own tan you're still screwed
they're still going to have unbelievably
good field positions yes you're right
and if you go for it on your own 10
fourth and one you have a reasonably
good chance of getting it and now all of
a sudden you're back in it wow but he
just said he couldn't do that he looked
he just looked me in the eye and said I
can't do that I'll lose my job so
um wow did he did he lose his job anyway
uh he went to the NFL he had a great
year for the Oregon Ducks he went to the
NFL he lost his job upwards that's
fantastic
said earlier on that about how machine
learning programs are getting quicker
are we gonna get to the point where we
can really start to predict some of the
big natural disasters the earthquakes
the tsunamis are you know it or is as
good as it gets right now I think let me
be more precise there there's certain uh
I don't know earthquakes wouldn't be the
best example here but certainly storms
where we have limits to how many days in
advance You can predict
the weather because there's some you
know chaos takes over yeah what how does
AI handle chaos any better than we've
ever handled it before
so those are sort of the same question
and I think that actually comes back to
this 5149 versus 100 zero thing so
predicting an earthquake that's a
hundred zero thing
how many hurricanes are going to be this
season that's more like a 5149 thing
dealing with chaos very much at 5149
thing the stock market is sort of
chaotic but I wanna I wanna I don't have
to get it right all the time I just want
to get it right
most of the time but I should just be
cleared that my audience knows more
precisely what we mean by chaos so what
we learned back I guess in the 70s and
80s that you can start a system out with
certain variables
having certain values and then you could
run a system and not all systems would
behave this way but some systems you get
a result okay and then you can make a
tiniest adjustment in your initial
parameters and then set it go let it go
forward and you get a completely
different result
so that small changes in your initial
conditions would not lead to small out
changes in your outcomes it led to huge
changes in your outcomes which meant
that your ability to predict far into
the future for some systems was
essentially mathematically impossible so
just so this is what I meant by chaos
here a butterfly flaps its wings in East
Africa and there's a hurricane six weeks
later in the Bahamas
and
my my answer is
you it's again it's the hundred Zero
versus 5149 I cannot tell you there will
be a hurricane in the Bahamas on October
27th
but I can tell you they're going to be
more hurricanes this year than average
in general more hurricanes 5149 this
specific hurricane that depends on that
specific butterfly
I don't know any better than I used to
how about Quantum Computing when you add
that into the effect because now you're
looking at billions and billions of data
points that are being fed to the AI so
Quantum Computing is good
I know less about it than I want to and
that I wish because I certainly have the
background
um
right now
conventional machines appear to be able
to process the data we need them to
process
and Quantum Computing I think will be
helpful in other ways Okay so
the quantum stuff
appears to be best at sort of doing an
almost uncountable number of things in
parallel
so I want to find an integer that has
certain properties
and I can sort of look at
hundreds of billions of interviewers
simultaneously using the quantum stuff
that's cool
but the machine learning stuff I'm just
trying to look for properties in
enormous data sets that involve sort of
looking at all the data and seeing how
it interacts with each other and that we
seem at least so far to be able to do
with it takes a lot of computing ton of
computing but we seem to be able
currently working there might be a way
to query that same set of data with the
higher performance Quantum Computing in
ways we had not thought to even ask data
maybe
interesting by the way about that
butterfly do you remember that article
in the Journal of irreproducible results
uh where
I think I said this on another episode
uh this is a journal where it's it's for
idle scientists who have some crazy
thought that is completely stupid but
they want to publish it anyway and so it
goes into the Journal of irreproducible
results so uh one of them was the
calculation that heaven is hotter than
hell and it looked at the thermodynamics
of Souls and how many people are Heaven
worthy versus hellworthy right added up
all the energy of the souls going into
heaven and it made Heaven much hotter so
stupid calculations like that one of
them was okay I was just gonna say the
problem is that hell does not have air
conditioning no and Heaven does so this
paper has this photo of a butterfly and
it said it captured the butterfly that
caused Hurricane Andrew
one prosecuted the one butterfly that
went to hell
what I think is most fearful for people
is when AI does not just the tasks we
give it better than we've ever done it
but when it
self learns
and achieves what some mild version of
what we might call consciousness and
this sort of artificial general
intelligence I think is the scariest
part of AI that
that gets that's been discussed in
recent months could you just comment on
where that is today
it is scary
um
I think that
what we need to understand is
what
this technology is actually doing
these things that we're dealing with
these generative AI programs they have
no notion of Truth they have no notion
of reality they have no notion of fact
all they're doing or morality or
anything right all they're doing is
trying to predict what an expert would
say just what words would come out of
his mouth
and
as a result they sort of don't know what
they're doing
they just know what someone might say I
don't think
we're anywhere near a point where these
things exhibit true general intelligence
we need to understand when we're at when
we're interacting with them
these things don't understand that
they're they don't understand there are
facts not that they don't understand the
facts they don't understand they don't
even know right so when I asked about
the phase of the moon and Chicken in
Denmark and I got back this long study
which didn't even exist you had no idea
and I actually asked it I said are you
sure
and it responded it said well I'm not
really that sure because this was the
only study I could find it's just
standing by it's non-facts and it has no
idea
that
this is not how you look at the world
what they call Mirage when it comes back
to hallucination hallucination it's
hallucination and it doesn't realize
it's it doesn't know it's made something
up right when we talk about making
something up right just the phrase
is identifying a distinction between
actual reality and whatever you're
saying these things don't know there is
an actual reality okay so is that a
necessary guard rail is is it is a
necessary guard rail to imbue the
digital intelligence with the concept of
these things that it will do you know
like what reality is what effect is what
truth is I mean is it necessary I don't
it would be good but I don't know how
you do it these things are so divorced
from the notion of a reality you can't
just say hey there are facts remember
that it's just not how they work it's
not right could the problem could the
problem be that these language model AI
uh machines are coming of age at a time
where the internet is filled with
non-facts so it's not its fault we fed
it junk food had it come around right at
the beginning of the internet where you
didn't have q Anon and all the rest of
this could might have performed a little
better the fact that the fact and it is
the fact that these things have no
notion of Truth would still be true
people have tried to curate the
information on which they are trained so
they're not trained on nonsense and they
still have this problem with
hallucinating the fact the problem is
they don't understand that there is an
abstract an abject reality in which that
of which they are apart and I think
you're right the problem is not the
programs the problem is us
we need to recognize
that these things are divorced from
reality we need to remember if I want a
website created it's going to do well if
I want to ask it is there a correlation
between these two crazy things that I
pulled out of the air it's going to do
badly and we shouldn't pay attention so
if somebody when I told my son I asked
Bard is there a correlation between the
phase of the moon and the amount of
chicken eaten in Denmark his immediate
response was don't ask for that that's
stupid
I do think there's going to be a job
here and it's going to be an important
job which is how do I take what I want
to know and it's like prompt program
what prompt do I give bard
to get back the most useful answer I can
and to avoid all the jump that's going
to be a thing they're going to be people
who are good at it they're going to be
classes that teach you how to do it it's
going to be a real skill that we are
going to need okay so now let's make
that a given what do you do and this may
be more philosophical than you know than
than your uh you know qualified to
answer I'm certainly not what do you do
with the people who purposefully
use the technology for the end of
misinformation
confusion and chaos
because even if you do everything that
you just said those agents can still
utilize the technology to do some
serious harm to society correct and I
think they will and I think this gets
back to what we were talking about
before I think you need to have trusted
sources
trust is going to become much more
valuable
because lack of trust is going to be
such so much more dangerous so you need
to have trusted sources you need to the
extent you can to have technology that
can help identify
generated images as opposed to real
images
so there's there's both a technical
problem there
can I produce software that tells me
this is fake this is real technical
problem and there's a social problem
how do I get people to care
that they're looking at real information
as opposed to to sort of garbage that's
half my life that's half my life as an
educator I believe you it's a and it's I
think it's it is a huge part of what
scientists need to do
in our responsibility to do it is even
greater now than it's ever been because
this is this is more than one facet this
is more than one facet I'm guessing now
because yes scientists and programmers
have a responsibility but the
legislation and I mean you can't make it
governmental because if I go do
something in another country that
government's got no power so who are you
going to get space force to oversee it
no that won't happen so who who will
bring to bear legislation and these Bad
actors keep them in their place it's
going to be a part well that'll have to
be part of what uh Matt was talking
about in the recognition portion you
would have to be able to recognize where
these Bad actors are like most of the
dark web you know where the people are
located you you actually know where they
are you know it's just that they are in
a country that's not going to do
anything to them so I just wonder if if
Bad actors here put civilization at risk
that calls for some kind of uh
International yes
totally I think I think that the so
first of all the technical problems here
are are hard and they're challenging and
they're important identifying generated
text versus non-generated text and I am
I am thrilled because I'm a technologist
and I get to spend my productive time
working on technical problems and I
don't have to solve the social problems
that's that's apparently Neil's job well
I'm so glad this all works out for you
right you don't have to worry about it
really I do care about the need to
inform people about what the technology
can do
I do think that this particular
technology is going to take this problem
that you mentioned that we have right
truth has become more elusive
and I think that
this technology potentially can make it
more elusive still
but it is still up to us and I think
it's still possible for us to say no
enough
we are going to be committed to actually
knowing
whether the sky is blue before we start
going telling all of our friends and
neighbors what color of the sky is we
should check
this guy really is blue
here's why I'm convinced here's my
source
yes it's trusted
so that's why I'm willing to talk to you
about it well part of me thinks that if
AI has these hallucinations and it
doesn't really know what truth is
there's nothing intelligent about it at
all
so it's been misnamed it's it's a
disruptive force in our culture and in
our society and maybe we should Rebrand
it as artificial idiocy
um
Neil you were trying to get me killed in
this closet in the back in the closet
let me just bring some summative remarks
here and get your final reaction Matt it
seems to me if deep fakes become so good
that no one can trust them
then that's basically the end of the
internet as any source of information
and that has a positive side to it
because it means for example let's look
at Q Anon it means Q Anon won't even
believe
that stuff that's wrong that it thought
was true because it doesn't trust it
because the the level of misinformation
would be so total that people who were
previously misinformed
will be worried that they'd be
misinformed
I think that the amount of
misinformation
can go up
I think there will always there I think
there's likely to always be an internet
I think that it's likely to always have
valuable
factual action not if you know no which
is which information and the trick is
going to be to find it and if you think
about the stuff that I talked about
on the technical side we need the
ability to find it and on the social
side we need to have the desire the
desire
a positive outcome if Q Anon can't even
believe this the stuff that's not true
isn't that a positive it might be that
might be a positive outcome in isolation
but if Q Anon has that problem then so
do all the people who are trying to
affect positive change well then that
brings us to something that we haven't
touched upon and that is our ability as
a as a society where the majority of
people
are scientifically literate and trained
as critical thinkers so that they know
exactly where to place their trust yeah
that that is really where the problem is
or can I put it back on me that I got to
Train everybody to think this way okay
now you know that that that's your job I
wanted to leave the blame on Matt at the
end of the show before we before we
leave the show Neil Matt you sang how AI
is learning at quicker speeds and is
going to get there sooner etc etc will
it not then solve its own solve this
problem for us therefore thank yourself
thank you I don't I don't see a reason
for to expect that it will it will
figure this problem out a Chuck I do
agree with you I think that people don't
have to be trained as scientists but I
think they need to be trained as
thinkers
they need to be able to understand the
information with which they're presented
and evaluate it relatively
dispassionately and I think that
education broadly education is going to
become much more important
as
we need it more it's also the case that
as machines start doing the drudgery
education becomes more important because
we've been freed from the drudgery we
get to do the fun hard stuff
people need to understand
what that is how they can contribute and
all that and all that and I think that's
going to happen I I mentioned education
then man sorry to cut across you but
people have handing in their homework or
their assignments created by AI are we
not I think that is are we not heading
down a path where Generations in the
future will not have any desire to
self-educate I think that I think the
answer that is no I think this thing
where kids are handing in homework
written by by Bard or what have you I
think this is a relatively I hope it's a
relatively temporary yeah really I agree
too and we'll we'll sort that out yeah
yeah I I thought edible it just means
that the school system values your
grades more than you value learning and
so you give them grades right and so
that that'll shift in a good way how the
school systems uh Place their value on
what it is to teach you something and it
may awaken with students it may awaken
in students a reckoning or recognizing
of that value themselves exactly you
know yes yeah exactly okay so before AI
takes us over and and exterminates us
there are these good sides of what I
think there are some there are some
short-term there's some short-term bumps
I mean the fact that they're going to be
so many deep things is going to be a
short-term up
but okay you know problems are always
opportunities in Disguise so the
commitment
to being able to recognize what's true
and what isn't the realization that
there are facts
that's something that I can see Society
embracing more than it has because it
has to because it has if you don't
believe in reality you get overrun so
maybe all right that's a good thing to
end this on thank you for finally
bringing us around some places some hope
plus that we gotta get Chuck and Gary
out of the closet yes please
it's been great to talk to you Matt
always good to have you on the show
thanks for coming coming around again
and this will not be the last time we
reach out to you so absolutely always
making sure always good to have you
Chuck Gary this has been StarTalk
special edition Neil deGrasse Tyson here
your personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]